it is my pleasure
to be hosting with rob siegel as he
shares with us
the 10 key attributes that organizations
will need to drive success
over the next decade and as products and
services combine digital
and physical capabilities rob researches
strategy and innovation
in both large and small companies as
well as the opportunities and challenges
that technological change brings to
these firms
specifically he explores how companies
combine
digital and physical solutions for the
customers
and at the stanford graduate school of
business robert teaches product
management and product development best
practices and methods
as well as entrepreneurial finance over
the life cycle of growing companies
rob go ahead and take it from here
thanks so much anita
good morning good afternoon or good
evening wherever you may be
uh it's wonderful to have all of you
here virtually at stanford university
what we're going to do for the next 45
or 15 minutes
is we're going to spend some time
looking at a topic
near and dear to my heart about how the
leading organizations
in the next decade or two are blending
the best of digital and physical
there's this notion of this idea that we
have companies that started with
a physical dna or a digital dna
and they stay very separate and what
we're seeing now in all the companies
that i study at the stanford graduate
school of business
is the best companies seem to be
blending the best capabilities
of both areas what we're going to do is
we're going to walk through a framework
that i call the brains and brawn
framework
which is going to look at five digital
or brain attributes
and five broad or physical attributes
and we can see some best practices of
companies
who are doing great things in each of
these 10 areas and in fact when we
finish
you'll be able to look at your company
and figure out how you're doing on these
vectors and then in the second part of
the talk we're going to talk about
systems leadership
these are the attributes of the leaders
that need to be able to help
guide and lead organizations over the
next decade or two going forward
so with that i'm going to dig in we're
going to master this not so digital
transformation
and first who am i so i'm rob siegel i'm
the short ball guy on the other side of
the camera
i like to say that i have two full-time
jobs and no life
i'm a full-time member of the gsb
faculty but i'm also a venture
capitalist here in silicon valley
where i'm involved in investing in a
variety of companies both very very
large and very very small when i was in
operating roles i actually worked at
intel corporation and i also ran a
division of ge
so i had time spent in some very large
organizations
but i was not always in big companies i
was also a many time entrepreneur
i started a company that made the
world's first digital picture frames
that was called weave innovations and it
got bought by
sony and then i worked for a company
called pixem that was spun out of the
engineering school here at stanford
and that company made image sensors and
image processors
i did my undergraduate work on the other
side of the bay university of california
berkeley
i did my graduate work at stanford i
actually do own a tie
and i have no idea where it is and once
upon a time
i used to have hair now this picture of
me with hair has nothing whatsoever to
do with anything we're going to talk
about
but i try to put it up whenever i can
just to remember the good old days
all right let's see if we can talk about
reframing what it takes to win
in a business context because i think
the way that we've looked at things in
the past
is not necessarily what it's going to be
like going forward
first and foremost we're dealing with a
new world order a new world order where
every product
is connected between the healthcare
industry in the financial services
industry
the mobility industry really isn't a
product that's not connected
i mean the fact that i am teaching you
today from my home office here
a lot of this was shaped by the pandemic
where i now have basically a television
studio at home
and i'm able to reach people all over
the world in ways that i couldn't do
before
it's much more than digital
transformation and
every industry is going to have to
combine these attributes of brains and
brawn
and in conjunction individuals are going
to need
need to be able to lead and lead in new
ways that it couldn't be done before
and the skill sets that made us
successful for are not what's going to
be
uh enough to help us on a go forward
basis
one of the examples i like to talk about
is we think of two companies
airbus and uber and i'll often ask
people i'll say
who's the digital company and who's the
physical company
and it's actually a trick question
because inevitably what happens
if someone says ah airbus that's the
physical company they make big airplanes
uber uber's the digital company because
i order the app
and order the car on my phone because
it's an app that i interact with
and one of the things i like to
highlight is that when you used to get
on airplanes before the pandemic and by
the way you're going to get back on
airplanes again soon
any flight you take that aircraft might
generate a terabyte of data
and uber at this moment in time is
moving people
we're all made of atoms and not bids
from one physical location
to another physical location and what's
interesting about that is if you think
about it
both airbus and uber are both digital
and physical
and yet given their dna each one has
various strengths
and some various development needs
airbus very good at systems engineering
government relations quality assurance
manufacturing
not as good at knowing how to make
information of data that comes from the
asset not a lot of good digital talent
natively
uber on the other hand is great at data
and great at logistics
not so good at driver relations not so
good at managing the government
and this is the thing where you think on
a go forward basis
each of these organizations have pluses
and minuses that will give them
strengths and development needs
now if we think about how products used
to be developed in the old days
in fact even when i was at ge the left
upper left side of
this picture kind of shows what it was
like you know you think of a company
maybe in the american organization
walmart
what made walmart great as an early
retailer is they owned assets and had a
great supply chain
they were analog products they knew had
if they could have high cell they could
deliver lower cost to consumers
product life cycles for products you
know used to take three plus years
but in a world where everything has a
digital component we see the nature of
how products are developed
they're changing now we can rent assets
again look at uber
where they don't own those assets they
actually the drivers
actually own the cars that are used or
db in china same sort of thing
network effects become increasingly
important the more people you have on a
network the more data you have on the
network the more valuable the network
becomes
daily product updates we think of
companies like yelp
yelp doesn't have a quality insurance
department because they send out a new
version of their software
every four hours what companies have
realized is
being quick and being responsive can
actually serve customers better
now you don't always want to build
products with you know agile and scrum
and
some of the newer ways of looking to
design products you actually want
aircraft engines to be designed
in some of the old methodologies but
even aircraft engines are being designed
on how you blend some of the old ways of
doing things with some of the new ways
of doing things
and if you're designing your products
differently you've got to think about
how do i organize my company and how do
i do that differently
so for example in the old days at six a
ge i was a six sigma black belt i knew
my p
values and i knew quality numbers and i
knew i had to make sure that i could
measure everything
decisions and organizations were done
intuitively and you had a hierarchy from
the most senior people
to the most junior people inside of the
organization i t
i t was seen as a cost center but now in
a world where everything's connected you
have to think about how you're going to
organize your company differently
it's about responsiveness and pushing
down capabilities
and decision making authority to those
who are closest to the customers
and that can be in a region or in
another part of the world
you need to be thinking about designing
for upside do i have a product that's
flexible that i can sell new products
and new services to people
think of a tesla if you want a tesla or
if you know somebody who owns a tesla
there are times you wake up and there's
new features and capabilities in your
car
you just don't see that with volkswagen
cars or toyota cars
or general motor vehicles and then
finally
i.t is seen as a revenue generator i.t
is seen as we need to have ongoing
contacts with our customers
so the whole mindset about how we
organize and how we think about
where we put people in the resources
that we fund in our companies becomes
very very different than a world
that is blending digital and physical
now the next two decades will bind us
both and the physical incumbents will
add digital
and the digital disruptors will end
physical but today's competitive
advantage
will be the companies that combine the
best of both of these and we're going to
walk through some examples
uh to show so i can show you this on
this slide here what you see is
i've studied over 70 or 80 organizations
many of whom have been guests in my
class or i've done research on them
or i've written cases on them where they
really understand that data
can have a huge impact on their ability
to serve their customers better
and everything that i'm going to talk
about in the next 35 or 40 minutes is
based upon two of the courses that i
teach
at the graduate school of business the
industrialist dilemma and systems
leadership
both of which are also available online
through stanford's
digital transformation certificate
program all right what i want us to do
is i want us to think about the brains
and broad
framework and this is a way for us to
kind of give some context and structure
for how we're going to look at things i
want to start first with the brainy
attributes and i'm going to explain what
they are
let's think about it our brain the left
hemisphere that's how we use analytics
the right hemisphere that's how we
manage creativity
the amygdala that's how we control the
empathy that we have for others
in our in our ecosystem and in our lives
the prefrontal cortex how do we manage
risk think about
fight or flight the lizard brain finally
the inner ear
how do we balance partnership versus
what we're going to own
and i know what you're thinking you're
thinking rob don't you know the inner
ear is not part of the brain i do know
the inner ear is not part of the brain
but it's kind of close so cut me some
slack
on the physical side the brawny
attributes what do we want to do on the
physical side
our spines how do we handle logistics in
an organization that keeps everything
from going and flowing so that the body
and the organization can
work our hands the craft of making
things can we manufacture well
muscles do we have size and scale when
can we operate on a global basis
hand-eye coordination can we drive our
ecosystems
and then finally stamina can we survive
for the long run
and the best organizations can use both
brains
and brawn to be successful in serving
their customers
now one of the things as we go through
this i want you to be thinking about
your organization where you work
and as we go through these 10 attributes
you can give your company
a one to ten rating on all
five brain and all five broad attributes
and at the end you'll get an overall
score
now one thing i want you to keep in mind
no company is going to get a 10 on all
of them
probably the one that i think scores the
highest on all of these as we think
about it right now
is amazon amazon does a great job the
purpose of the framework however
is to allow us to see what it is that
where we have
where we have strengths and where we
have deficiencies and think about how we
might be able to invest
to improve our scores all right let's
talk a little bit about specifics
of each of these 10 attributes number
one let's talk about the left hemisphere
using analytics
everyone wants to talk about how data is
the new oil and
how data is so important but it's much
much more than just the ability to have
a lot of data
in fact what i found in my research is
the companies that did the best in
understanding how to use data data was a
tool
to serve their customers better one of
the companies that i spent extensive
time looking at was charles schwab
the large american financial services
company which has about seven trillion
dollars in assets
deposited at the uh the organization
they become a real powerhouse
inside of financial services united
states
one of the things that they always do
and they always talk about
is looking at what customers would want
through clients eyes anytime they take
an action one of the questions they will
ask themselves is
what do our customers want and how would
our customers want us to use that data
like here's a great example if it's
possible that somebody goes onto the
schwab website
and might type in what happens to assets
during a divorce
schwab might know exactly that you might
be headed towards
a marital change now they could then use
that data to their advantage
but they might not think that that's the
best thing that the customer might want
and as i studied schwab and i looked
about how they use all of this data they
collect
every time then when they would ask
about what to do with this data is
what would the customer want us to do
with the data to serve the customer
better
perhaps the best juxtaposition showing
the opposite of this is i'm going to
argue facebook
facebook's question seems to be with all
of our data what can facebook do that's
good for facebook can they sell our data
can they give it to other people so that
they can sell us things and so that they
can
improve their bottom line with never
once asking
what might the customers want if
facebook were asking those questions of
what customers want
they'd be making very different choices
about privacy and our ability to control
the data
now if you can be good at data you can
be much much better
than people who are in your industry but
on the other hand
and this is what's also tricky about
this if you think about those companies
who are good at data
those might be people who could enter
your industry when i spent time with the
leadership of schwab
there was a lot of speculation of what
happens if companies like google
or facebook or amazon enter into the
financial services business
they will also have a lot of data and
data in areas that you won't have
so the great thing about the left
hemisphere and thinking about how to use
data is every company
needs to become a data company but the
best companies that we studied
used a kind of almost north star about
what was the metric by making sure they
were using data responsibly
ethically and for the best purposes of
the customers
all right let's talk about the next part
of the brainy attributes
let's talk about creativity creativity
is all about
things that allows us to kind of come up
with brave new ideas but sometimes
it's not just kind of something new like
a lightning bolt that hits us out of the
sky
sometimes it's kind of grinding
creativity and it can be and we'll all
call
unsexy markets you know you're gonna
have creativity on a
variety of various attributes the
mindset a creative mindset are you open
to new ideas
do you try to develop new technologies
how do you think about your markets and
your customers
can you change your business model can
you figure out how to grow your
organization in ways that you couldn't
do before
and also how do you think about
creativity to defend yourself how do you
think
if i were going to attack my company how
would i attack my company if i were a
startup and i wanted to come after my
company
the best company that we set in the
space on creativity strangely enough
was a company called align technology
align technology
makes the invisalign uh teeth
straightening these plastic molds in
fact
here's mine because i'm actually
finishing my my teeth straightening
right now
these plastic clear aligners replace
braces
right the brackets and wires that we put
on our teeth and what a bunch of uh
pretty pretty smart people who graduated
from the stanford graduate school of
business in the late 90s what they
figured out
is that plastic can actually be used to
change individual teeth inside of our
mouths
and then we're much safer and more
convenient than putting brackets and
wires in our mouth because those are
kind of clunky and ugly
and if a wire breaks it really hurts it
can poke the side of your cheek
and the great thing about the plastic
aligners is it can be
very very very precise in the movements
in our mouth that it creates so
every solution that they create is
highly customized
and what a line does is they digitize a
picture of your mouth
and they can actually come up with a cad
model that will move individual teeth
and give you the exact smile you want
and what they learned
was that smile might vary in terms of
what's attractive
depending upon what part of the world
you're in strangely enough as i was
studying this i learned
what people in north america might find
is an attractive smile
is different than south america it's
different than southeast asia
it's different than europe it's
different than australia
there are certain cultural norms and
what we found was that a line can
actually give you a highly customized
smile
but they did something even more
interesting not only
did they have a new technology to figure
out how to straighten people's teeth
but they went after a new business model
because they made it
so simple to straighten people's teeth
that actually they now start selling
through dentists as well as
orthodontists
in the old days dentists and
orthodontists were in different parts of
the market the orthodontist straightened
our teeth
and the dentist cleaned our teeth and
what a line figured out
is their product was so simple they
could actually expand their market
on their channel sites so that dentists
could add revenue to their business
and that's an example of the kind of the
creativity not just thinking about
how do i build a better product but are
there better ways to deliver it to
people
that can help us grow the market all
right third what's another good brainy
attribute
yamagawa the power of empathy empathy is
something that's talked about a lot in
modern culture today the importance of
empathy the value of empathy
and it's more than just putting
yourselves in customer shoes
it's also about managing and aligning
incentives between you
and your customer the best example i
ever saw of this
was kaiser permanente the verbal
vertically oriented
care company here in north america where
in the case of uh
other companies kaiser's unique they are
both hospitals
doctors and insurance company they own
the whole dollar of health care
for their members and what they figured
out
was the way for that company to be the
most effective and most successful
was that if they could keep their pay
their members
alive as long as possible and healthy as
long as possible
they actually made more money think
about that
healthy life years was the figure of
merit and is the figure of merit
for kaiser permanente so they figure out
how to measure and align incentives
for their customers and they put that
throughout their whole organization
to make sure that doctors nurses people
on the administrative side
are understanding what is the figure of
merit by which they're measuring their
success
it's almost this notion of radical
empathy for all the ceo who i got to
know was a gentleman named bernard tyson
one of the most amazing and compelling
leaders that i ever met
unfortunately bernard passed away uh
last year was just an absolute tragedy
he left us way too soon
but i remember when he would come to
class he could hold the students in the
palm of his hands
and talk about what it was like dealing
with patients dealing with doctors
dealing with the government
and he always felt he always felt that
he had an understanding
of where the other side was coming from
and it
engendered a fierce loyalty from many of
the employees there
and our students like we're like god i
want to work for that guy it was an
amazing thing to see
all right what is the fourth brainy
attribute that i want us to talk about
making risk right sometimes we want to
take smart risks and you got to do that
if you're going to be able to innovate
and try
something that will transform your
company and one of the things that we
talk about
is you've got to run towards the
disruption you cannot be afraid of a
disruption that's coming after your
industry
oftentimes we get conservative in times
of disruption we're afraid
to run towards the disruption because we
want to preserve ourselves on the other
hand
if you don't run towards the disruption
you won't get to the other side
in a leadership position you've got to
be thinking about
how might things be different and how
can we leverage that for success we have
to learn to let go of the past
how can we get more data and use less
intuition and realize that it's personal
my best example of this is abndab the
large
world's largest beer company carlos
brito who is actually also in alum of
stanford
was actually in 2015 he got in a lot of
trouble with his board of directors
this wonderful organization had been
built through a series of acquisitions
and they've gotten so big they weren't
doing innovative things they kind of had
this
this business model of acquire and drive
out cost
and so burrito was really just getting
hammered by his board that they weren't
trying new things
craft beers were coming up bud and
budweiser were
you know budweiser light were less
popular with people
and so he realized that he had to make
some changes and he went to one of his
top lieutenants
a gentleman named pedro pedro work and
said pedro
i want you to become the chief
disruptive growth officer
and pedro looked at burrito and said
what does that mean
and burrito looked at him and said go
figure it out you need to figure out how
to make us more innovative
earp then had to figure out what does it
mean to how do i build
an organization for innovation that
doesn't even exist inside of the 60
billion
a year company and then culturally how
do i make that happen
and he thought about it some more he
went back to burrito and he said breta
how do i know if i've been successful i
mean even if i take five years
that's not going to have that big of an
impact on our organization
he said you'll get the ball rolling and
the most important figure of america
that will know
pedro is that if your job is no longer
necessary
because you have infected the thinking
into the dna of the organization about
how to be innovative
basically that's when we'll know you
succeeded when your job no longer exists
and irv had to sit there and say okay
i've got this rocket ship career going
on at ab indepth
and the ceo wants me to do this new job
and i only
know that i'm successful that was about
managing risk
the upside for dealing with this was he
realized that if he could
really impact the organization and
change the organization
it was going to give a b indep the
opportunity to grow and thrive
in the next couple of decades and in
absence of it
they were going to die but he also knew
that if he succeeded
he was going to be out of a job and he
would have to trust
that burrito would take care of him in
the future
this notion of managing risk you have to
take smart risks and what
pedro realized is that if he didn't go
in and do this
the company was going to be in trouble
and so one of the things that i want you
to be thinking about with your own
organization
is how are you managing risk inside of
your organization as a company
and even as an individual and are you
taking the bold steps of what abn bev
did
they actually set up a whole division
called zx which is
does corporate venture capital you know
there's a there's a venture group inside
of it there's an innovation group
they work very closely with the business
units across the company and it's become
one of the fundamentally most important
parts of the business
it was not easy to set it up but they
got it done
right the next thing i want us to think
about in brains is that
balancing partnerships with what we do
on our own
one of the ways i like to think about is
if you think of a castle you know how
castles have walls and moats to keep
people out
one of the questions that companies need
to think about is where are they going
to put their castle walls
how far out do they want to have stuff
inside of the castle
and what do they want to have maybe be
part of the surrounding kingdom
but not inside the castle walls should
you go it alone should you partner
and you know how are you going to think
through what do you want to own and what
do you not want to own
instacart the grocery delivery company
inside the united states i think does an
amazing job
of figuring out where to partner and
what to own they have to deal with a
bunch of
key different constituencies and they've
got four key constituencies they have to
manage
they have to manage their shoppers
people who actually go into the stores
and buy the groceries
they have to deal with the grocery
stores themselves they actually
have to work with us as consumers if we
want to shop at instacart
and then finally they partner with the
consumer package companies and the cpg
companies
because they understand as instacart
across across a wide variety of stores
and locations
what products are moving in what areas
and how is that changing based upon the
buyers
they get a granularity of data that the
cpg companies are very excited about
and one of the things that as instacart
has grown they went from
you know in the early days being a
startup that didn't have a lot of power
and influence over people
to actually be very very powerful
especially in this space
and so they had to figure out what did
they want to own what do they want to
partner with people
and that's a very delicate balance when
you're dealing with these multiple
constituencies
in your market the thing that i would
say that was interesting when we studied
instacart that i found fascinating
is sometimes there were benefits to not
being amazon
if you think about instacart they had
this great relationship with a company
called whole foods
whole foods got bought by amazon and
that was instacarts like key clients
and then all of a sudden some whole
foods got bought by amazon and the ceo
of whole foods called the ceo of
instacart and said
yeah amazon bought us we're not going to
do business with you anymore click
the ceo of instacart said yeah that was
the worst day he ever had in business
but the next day was actually the best
day he ever had in business
because grocery stores you know chains
two through eight
all called them up and said hi amazon
just came in our business
we need help delivering groceries to
people houses and suddenly instacart's
business tripled overnight
that's the ability of how do you figure
out how to turn a headwind into a
tailwind
all right those are the brainy aspects
those are the brainy things we've talked
about again left hemisphere right
hemisphere amygdala prefrontal cortex
uh and inner ear let's talk about the
brawny side let's talk a little about
logistics
three american retailers that have
survived and maybe shouldn't have let's
look at best buy and home depot and
target
all of them kind of figured out that
they needed to embrace e-commerce but
figure out how to benefit from having a
physical location
and actually having great logistics was
the way that served customers better
yuberjoli
the former ceo of best buy he started
calling everybody in the abyss
you know he should have gone out of
business best buy should have gone out
of business like other american
electronics retailers
but he started calling all the people
who were making these connected products
he called apple he called amazon
and he said hey how's business and
they're like business is awesome right
you know we're loving this
everything's connected it's great and so
jolie tried to figure out how did he
redefine
what best spy is and he realized that if
you're in a
company you're in an organization you've
got an i.t department
but inside of your home you're now
working with a bunch of products that
are connected
and you don't have an i.t department so
best buy realized
if they could become a company that we
go to as consumers
when we want to figure out why is the
internet not working on the television
why is it not working on this particular
device he believed people would buy the
consumer electronics products from best
buy
but they'd also come to them for the
service side which would give an ongoing
relationship
and he said these headwinds where people
were able to buy an e-commerce and shop
prices
if he could figure out how to turn that
into a tailwind where he could make
shopping easier and he could service his
customers better
that's what allowed best buy over the
last seven years to be a retail success
story
and when he retired a couple of years
ago you jolie went out as one of the
leaders
of american business in the last eight
years who really turned around a company
home depot craig mini are the ceo one of
the things he taught us is that people
want to shop online
by the way he came to this conclusion
before the pandemic he's like don't
fight the inevitable
don't fight the inevitable if your
customers want to start the shopping
experience
through their computers right you know
the good news is
a sync does not ship well through amazon
prime
so they figured out that if they could
give customers a better interface on the
digital because that's what the
customers want to do
and they could have you know lumber or
something people want to buy for a home
improvement available at your local
store
within two hours that would be a better
consumer experience
and logistics became the competitive
advantage that's allowed home depot to
boom
hugely over the last five years finally
target
brian cornell the ceo would talk about
blurring and blending
that it's not this notion of e-commerce
versus physical commerce
it's just commerce and people are
shopping together the ability to shop
online
and you can have the groceries and
everything you buy at target delivered
into your car for curbside pickup
this is this notion of blending digital
and physical and we've seen it at
retailers
and the key to make it happen was
amazing logistics
now sometimes there's some great new
technologies that are coming in
hands the craft of making things
manufacturing
is transforming hugely on a global basis
right now
as labor becomes a lower and lower
component
of manufacturing right this notion that
you're going to want to be able to use
new technologies whether it's robotics
or additive manufacturing like what
desktop metal is doing which is now
you can build a product by like
depositing layers
of materials it can be metal it can be
composites in ways that you couldn't do
before you've got these machines
and you can put the machines wherever
you want them there are companies for
example some of the large oil companies
that will put these machines actually
out you know on on
on oil platforms in the middle of the
ocean that have apart breaks they can
print a new part and smoke as opposed to
having to fly in a replacement part
it changes the notion about how we think
about making things and we have the
ability
to have higher quality products with new
manufacturing capabilities
when actually lower delivered costs to
customers
humans need to be part of the loop on
this and so what we found was that it's
not that humans are going to go away
but how humans will work in
manufacturing it changes
it goes from being kind of a low-cost
labor arbitrage opportunity to now
needing highly skilled people to
understand how to work the machines how
to program the machines
and how to really understand how your
customers are going to be using the
products that you make for them
and everything is going to be connected
and we're going to move to a world where
you have high volume
and high value and high touch as opposed
to the overall where we have high volume
and low cost or high value and high
touch now we're going to get the best of
both
the third attribute in physical is
leveraging
scale operating on a global basis think
about this i know there were over 2 000
people signed up
for this webinar and i have no idea
where in the world you are
you could be anywhere since the pandemic
has hit i have run from my home office
here
seminars for people in riyadh saudi
arabia
in sao paulo in brazil in cologne
germany in chicago basically jakarta
you know there's not a continent that i
haven't touched in doing this
and this idea that you can operate at
scale is becoming increasingly important
you uh i foreign ago who is the ceo of
michelin the french tire company
taught me the phrase glocal where you
have a global
footprint which you have the ability to
customize on a local level
for michelin the way they think about it
is they have a material science platform
and competency
that can be applied to different types
of tires for anywhere on the planet
but the tires they sell in china versus
the tires that they sell in north
america
versus the tires they sell in europe can
be customized to the local markets
based upon the needs of the local market
and that ability to operate at scale
it's not just about having a lot of data
where you can feed the machines to be
better but can you operate
physically at scale on a global basis
but
customize for local markets this is one
of the things where we're seeing some
similarities
by the way between brains and brawn and
by the way where they can be positively
reinforced
the digital advantage can really change
the nature
of what it is that you can do and the
reach with which you can talk to
customers
all over the world all right fourth
let's talk about hand-eye coordination
we often about sports and hand-eye
coordination best example i've this
that i've seen is google and in
particular their android division for
mobile phones
the complexity of their ecosystem is
staggering
they have to deal with carriers who you
know deal with
the networks with which our calls and
our data run on the phone the handset
manufacturers
the application developers who build the
apps on top of android
they got to deal with global governments
right because governments are
concerned about privacy and data
customers we have to use the products
advertisers because that's all part of
the the how google makes money
and the component suppliers that
actually the the people who make the
chips and the like that go into the
phones
these are all part of the android
ecosystem and all those
parts interact with each other one of
the things to think about as you think
about
all of these people in the ecosystem is
what is your
influence on these various parties and
what's your dependence on them
and really in a perfect world you want
to have high influence and low
dependence right because there you have
the ability
to kind of influence what other
ecosystem partners do and you know if
you're not dependent upon them and you
have options
you will have choices but there are
times when actually you're going to be
dependent upon somebody
and you're going to have very low
influence and when that happens you will
have less power
so if people talk about ecosystems and
wanting to build an ecosystem
you actually need to think more
strategically about what are the
dynamics behind an ecosystem
versus what companies can do inside of
that ecosystem and by the way the
government
yeah whether you do or don't want
government to be your business partner
government's going to be your business
partner
this trend was already being accelerated
by you saw a lot of the geopolitical
tensions in the world right now
maybe at one level exacerbated the most
by the tension between the united states
and china
but the pandemic has just made that even
more intense if you
look at the amount of stimulus that is
happening on the global basis
where money is being pushed into the
economy governments are getting
more and more and more involved with
business business
becomes about national industrialist
policy and given that
every country is going to have an
industrial policy for the needs of
jobs and employment for people in a
particular market
companies are going to need to know how
to work with various governments all
over the world
and understand the differences of what
the incentives are of governments all
over the world
lastly on lebron thing let's talk about
stamina
and how do we survive in the long run my
favorite example of this is johnson and
johnson the large pharmaceutical company
they are driven by this message of
what's called the credo which talks
about the four constituencies
that they serve by the way the first and
most important one is the patient
and the last one is the shareholders
they are often talking about bending
their business lines so they're not
dependent
just upon one on one product or one kind
of grouping of products
that actually if you have a various set
of adjacencies you can survive more over
time in the ups and downs
of economic cycles you want to nurture
ongoing innovation on
ongoing innovation needs to be something
that's built into the dna of your
company
and you need to build resilience to the
culture and your values
all right those are our brains and broad
attributes if we look at them here's the
summary again on the screen of what i
talked about
let's actually look at a couple of
companies we can look and see i actually
analyzed two companies and talked about
how they're doing
first daimler the very well-known and
very successful german automotive
company
when i wrote my case on daimler i looked
at the five
digital attributes the five brain
attributes and you can see the scores
that are up there
actually not that good they were not
that great at analytics
creativity okay at least on the physical
side the amygdala empathy not so much
right you know they were
not they didn't really seem to
understand a lot of what was happening
in the ecosystem and how things were
changing and how they would react to it
risk taking they were pretty
conservative the inner balancing
partnership versus ownership
they seem to want to hold on to a lot of
things themselves of course on the
brawny side they were great like this is
a company that makes beautiful cars that
are really
really well built and you see they got a
final score of 65 out of 100.
another example 23andme which is an
american company
that actually does uh sequencing of
human dna
and now they've moved into the
pharmaceutical business in a
collaboration with gsk
i mean analytics they they have 12
million samples of people's dna and they
can understand what are trends about
how people shape who we are and what we
do
creativity and empathy they're great at
it or they're not as strong
as manufacturing they obviously don't
know how to make things they work very
closely
with gsk for drug manufacturing and they
when we added up all their numbers came
up with 82 out of 100.
now it's not that this is going to be a
permanent evaluation a number of these
companies but you can start to get a
sense of why might a company be doing
well
why why my accompanying company be
struggling because you can see how they
do
on these attributes of brains and brawn
and so this was an example of how you
can come up with a total score
and you can think about it for your own
company all right
that's brains and brawn let's talk about
the system's leadership side what do you
need what skills do you need as a leader
the world requires a new cent type of
leadership for this
systems leadership i define is the
ability to understand the interactions
between various groups
and be able to master strategies from
different perspectives
at the same time you can't just stay in
a particular function like marketing or
sales or engineering or manufacturing
and rise up and be an expert in that and
then not really have expertise on what's
going on
you need to understand how you
simultaneously manage for the short term
and the long term
at the same time how do you understand
what's happening inside of your company
between functions
and also how your company is interacting
with other groups that are outside of
your company
you need to blend iq and eq and you need
to make sure that you have the big
picture of what's going on
but you also need to be on top of
details kind of in the old days we were
able to keep these things separate
but i would argue in a world that's
blending digital and physical where
things are more inexorably intertwined
you have to be able to do the same thing
here where you've got to be able
as a leader to be able to do both of
these things
let's look at some best examples of how
we
of great leaders that we studied the
first column that you see in
in france this is gets to what i call
the duality of the systems leader
the digital thinker these are people who
come from silicon valley they think
platform and horizontal they think
software they think winner take all
employees or gig the physical thinker
vertical
asset based continuous improvement you
know
work very closely with a customer
systems leaders
combine the best of both of those things
they understand both hardware and
software
they understand that again like i talked
about in the context of michelin
a global platform that can be applied
locally or even like we saw with align
technologies with the teeth straightener
right they have a platform that can
straighten teeth anywhere but each
set of plastic aligners that they make
is customized for the individual
you think about being balanced with a
view towards government this is what
systems leaders need to be able to do on
a go forward basis
and they have to be able to drive change
in their organization they need to be
able to recognize
patterns discover intersections between
things that weren't there previously
they need to figure out how to adapt
their business models optimize more
structure
all while taking actions figure out what
technical stack what
technology you're going to have in-house
how are you going to organize your
ecosystem
and how you're going to sustain the
business over time and by the way the
hard part this right now
is you have to do it through times of
incredible disruption and uncertainty
like i was trained to be a teacher like
being a teacher like it's an apprentice
business
with what you're all going through in
the commercial side there's much less
determinism and much less dependability
on what's going to happen on the other
side
some of the best things we learned is
the great leaders that we studied
were preparing for the future of work
they were thinking about you know from a
technical side
of all of the technologies on the left
side of the screen
you know robotics autonomous ai and ml
and then they thought about different
parts of their organization
they thought about different parts about
you know what it is that they needed to
be doing about it in administration and
on manufacturing et cetera and then they
had to make decisions what were we going
to make and what are we going to buy
what are the id source and what are we
going to outsource what are we going to
share
what are we going to not share by the
way how are we going to retrain our
labor force
one of the things i want you all to be
thinking about is the displacement of
labor and capital that happened with
globalization 1.0
we all could have anticipated it the
communication and collaboration tools
that we're using even here right now and
all of these things are
just going to continue we know there's
going to be the next set of jobs
that we know are going to be disrupted
and the question is what sort of
training will you do for your labor
force because if you think about your
company
i bet you can guess what jobs are going
to go away in the next five years
and my question for you is what are you
going to be doing to help your teammates
systems leaders think about stuff like
that all right i want to talk about bias
we are all biased every human being on
the planet is biased we are a function
of all those things that we learned and
our experiences
and how we grew up our culture the way
we were trained etc
one of the things i find that great
systems leaders do
is they are not only aware of their bias
and by the way bias is not a bad word it
just is what it is
but who are the people outside of the
company who are the people outside of
the company that will tell them the
truth
do you have trusted partners outside of
your organization that you can go to and
say hey
here's how we're looking at the world
does that align with how you're seeing
things
how does your company look at what's
going on these are some of the key
things about how you manage
the constraints that we have as leaders
and the blind spots that we have as
leaders
by making sure we have people outside of
the organization who can help us
truth truth is an important thing right
but truth is actually facts plus context
let me say that again
truth for your team and your audience
are facts plus context
look facts are facts but context is the
way in which we understand these things
let's think about globalization
globalization in the old days was great
right we
we make things and we do work in certain
parts of the world where people have a
competitive advantage we all benefit
from better products that maybe cost
less but in today's world the context
about this is it's not just about lower
priced products but it's about what
happens to jobs
what happens to our fellow citizens and
that's become the truth in the narrative
and what i would argue is that systems
leaders have to be able to communicate
truths
by understanding both the facts and the
context by which you yourself
and your employees are understanding how
the world is changing
and how all this data is understood and
the systems leader really needs to have
the grasp of both the facts and the
context
so that she or he can help communicate
truth
to their team there are four ways
that every systems leader needs to know
i talked a bit about technology i just
want to highlight four of them
that i think are critical that are
impacting every industry artificial
intelligence
additive manufacturing desktop metal as
an example analytics and data
and finally automation these four trends
are
shaping every company on the planet you
need to have an opinion on these four
trends and how they're impacting your
company you don't have to be an expert
in any of these things you don't have to
be able to be
sling code but you better be conversant
you better be able to understand what
these technologies are and what the
impact it's going to be
on your company systems leaders need to
sometimes understand the big fundamental
changes that are happening
technologically to us
and what the impact is going to be on
the companies in which you work
given all these changes and given that
the world is changing
one of the things that i learned from
katrina lake the executive chairman
of stitch fix and the co the founder of
stitchfix is she asks herself and her
team every two years
would you rehire yourself for your job
today
that if your job was an open job wreck
would you hire yourself
that's a very scary question like
you have to ask yourself have i kept
myself current
am i on top of the latest things going
on systems leaders
know that they would make sure that at
the moment in time they are
at least competitive if not the best
person for the job that you have
oftentimes we get constrained because we
got rewarded by all the things about how
things were done in the past we got
promoted
we got paid more money we got bigger job
titles we got a bigger office
because we had done certain things and
then the world has changed on us
and the best thing for you to figure out
is that if you're not bringing
the most current skills make sure that
you know that
before anybody else does and if you've
got to keep yourself fresh in fact
maybe that's why you're listening to
this webinar make sure you're asking
yourself
would you rehire yourself for your job
today and if not
what are you gonna do about it all right
a couple of final comments before we
wrap
up leader know thyself great systems
leaders
know their own strengths and their own
development needs in my case
my greatest strength it's my passion and
my energy oh my goodness
you know i'm in front of the classroom i
like to run up and down the aisles i
can't wait to like get back in the class
they even put me in front of a camera i
can try to create a bunch of energy and
wave my arms around and
try to have some fun even though i can't
see you i'm just looking into a camera
but my passion can also be my greatest
development need
and i think the best example of that is
when i was younger
when i was younger i used to send
the most amazing flame emails that you
could possibly imagine
like i would see email that would come
in right and it would just get me angry
and i'd hit reply all and i'd start
writing and
what i would write everything i write it
was they were it was accurate
it was sarcastic it was
cutting and it was always ineffective
always ineffective i had to realize wait
a minute my passion
that which gets me going and can
actually be a real
benefit can be a real hindrance if i'm
not careful
so i've learned as i've gotten older as
my beard has gotten more gray
that if i see an email that kind of gets
at me and
triggers me i have to learn to back away
from the keyboard
and not react in fact one of the things
that i remember learning
earlier in my career was that leadership
is the ability to constrain a response
to a given stimulus and for me those
emails that used to make me so upset
those were the stimuli that used to
really that i have to learn not to
respond to
okay now we finish this we talked about
brain brawn and the blending of digital
and physical
we talked about the needs for systems
leaders now you might be looking at me
and say
okay so now what what do i do about it
all right i usually ask when i talk to
clients or i talk to large organizations
if i'm doing executive education
i prompt people more questions what do
these changes mean for your customers
don't start with yourself start with
your customers and the people you serve
what's happening to them
if you know what's happening to them
that will help you with that empathy
capability right if you understand what
their business is and where are they
under stress
secondly where can your company develop
an unfair competitive advantage like
what do you already do that you don't
want to let go of
what do you want to kind of hold on to
third
what is your company not doing today
that it needs to be doing
i bet you already know what your company
needs to be doing that it's not doing
and then finally as a systems leader how
will you change your leadership
behaviors and actions
as we go through this world as we go
through these changes one of the things
i want to leave you with is the
following
you can do this there's nothing that
i've talked about that can't be done
you know there's this notion sometimes
people need to have this great
technological innovation breakthrough
like you need to bend light in a way
that light's never been bent before
that's not this you can do
and make these changes of what i'm
talking about it's a choice
and you just have to decide if you want
to make that choice or not what i know
when i work with companies and leaders
all over the world
most of them can do it and want to do it
and they have to start that process
of moving forward with that i've been
talking for the last 50 minutes so we're
going to leave 10 minutes for q
a so i'm going to ask anita and or the
team
if we want to kind of now go to the q a
part of this webinar so anita or
whoever's going to help please jump in
now
excellent uh rob thank you very much
from
excellent presentation very exciting we
do have
many questions um so let's go ahead and
get started with the first one
and let's see here do you have
suggestions for how to implement these
approaches and concepts
in a small company versus a large
company you gave a lot of examples about
very large companies
um but say you're maybe not
a mom and pop but a smaller company
trying to make it big
what do you suggest it's a great
question
you know i i think that the in the early
days we talked about
in startups right and i have a
multi-time entrepreneur
you don't have time for discipline
you're moving fast and breaking things
and and what i would say is that a lot
of these behaviors kind of get
baked into the organization kind of in
the earliest days
so for example are you thinking
systematically about kind of what's
happening in your market
it's not just about a technological
innovation or it's not you know
even if you're in a non-technical
business are you understanding kind of
what's happening in the broader baby
if you've got a a retail store what's
happening in the broader area
who's your competition there's also
making sure you're hiring
teammates who have complementary skill
sets you could be starting to think
about well
what data do you have in your company my
guess is your company has some data
are you starting to think about how to
use that data
are you starting to think about um you
know where are you going to take risks
and where you take smart risks and where
not what creativity things can you come
up with
i think if you look at the 10 variables
and the 10 attributes
you know even some of the the companies
that you say they're large
but they started some of them started
pretty recently instacart's only been
around
less than a decade uh 23 in me it's 15
years
desktop metal eight years so a lot of
these companies are
fairly recent but they tried to figure
out how to use these these ways of
thinking and doing things to actually
drive scale
so there's a bit of a chicken and egg
thing the question is not necessarily
what how what does a small company do
i guess i might say how can these tools
perhaps create opportunities for growth
that you might not be exploring or
understanding today
so again these are by the way with
everything i say use what you like and
ignore what you don't
these are tools and try to see how these
tools can help you change
your own personal behaviors or think
about ways in which you're running your
business
super thank you um we actually have a
few
questions that are related back to slide
that was the radical transformation when
you were doing the comparing go ahead
and if you want to go and switch the
slide
yeah um this one and yeah
yes and a number of questions of how to
make the assessment
more objective how to do the calculation
um and what process would one take
um to make it more again objective
yeah you know it's kind of like grading
my students when they hand in papers
that there's some subjectivity that's
going to come into this
i do know for example when a student
writes a paper did they cite the
readings did they talk about what we
talked about in class you know
were people actually doing it so there
are heuristics that i use
i think with each one of these things
you know if you broke it down for
example analytics let's look at daimler
and and 23m i know the nature and size
of the database
that 23andme is using and how they think
about it for customer outcomes
and i don't and i also know what daimler
is and isn't doing
for and at least when i wrote the case
what they were doing with all the data
that they had
or if they were working on data but only
in a small part of the business maybe
just the manufacturing side or
performance side
but they completely ignored any customer
data or or you know
how they were shaping the information on
the the quality and service to design
products better for their customers
creativity you know this kind of got to
what are the things that i studied in
organization what did they do that i
thought was unique and outside of the
box
and then were there multiple examples of
it um
versus were some worth people being very
constrained in their thinking
so you try to figure out you can try to
think through and again this is i talk
about it in
in some of my writings but you know you
look for examples of things that people
are doing in these things and are they
doing a lot of it or a little of it
and so and by the way not everybody's
going to be perfect at everything
but you you know and sometimes you kind
of know when you see it when you say
okay look
let's talk about empathy um other
companies that do empathy really well
sas there's a software company uh that
is known for making taking care of its
people
uh patagonia same sort of thing um so
you can kind of like you know it when
you see it and then you can say well
if that's the best practice that i've
seen somewhere else what are they doing
you can write it down
and then you can say well what are we
doing or what are we not doing
like you can kind of like you can make
up your own scale like give it a score
like you can say i think this company's
at a 10 and a third of 10 were the six
the thing about this don't don't worry
about false specificity
don't worry too much that you've got to
get the score perfect what you're going
to find pretty quickly
is that if you're thoughtful about how
you go through each of these things
and you kind of like define a 10 and
define a one in your industry
and then you rate yourself by the end
you're going to get to an overall score
that's going to be pretty close to
accurate
so if diet is should daimler be 65 or 68
or 62
okay fine they're going to be in the 60s
similarly with 23andme should it be an
85 and 82 or 78
we know that they're doing well on these
attributes in a variety of areas and we
can compare them
to others in the industry so we know
that whether or not
what the absolute score is can be also
based upon what the relative score is
versus the competition
great thank you um one other question we
have and this
has come up a couple times is how does
one
bring these concepts ideas approaches to
the other people in the organization
whether it's a company a department
you know how do you know i i take these
courses
i learn the material but how do i then
bring them to others and then
implement real change well actually
it's interesting that's a two-part
process that i that i heard that
question anybody
the first is the successful one is is
like i often think of it as sharing i
read this really interesting article
here are the top two or three points
that i learned from it
here's the rest of it if you want to
learn more so you you share the
information in a positive way
maybe it's an inspiring way um and and
you you give kind of like people like
the most important message of what you
think
you know stands out and what applies to
your company and then you give them the
ability to go deeper if they want to
uh and know everybody loves somebody
who's an energy giver versus an energy
taker
like so if you're excited about
something this is awesome because the
first is
kind of deliver the message in a
positive way and make it kind of
digestible
for your teammates driving change is a
hard one right
and it gets easier in some respects the
more senior you get because you have
position power and authority
but it can also be harder because you
can be more isolated
and so you're going to have to figure
out how to work with your teammates and
your colleagues
to actually get these things going on
you want to build consensus
with some key teammates so that you
don't have to do it all alone
uh you know one of my sayings i like to
say individuals don't win championships
teams win championships
so with that kind of mindset can you
build some natural allies
inside of the organization who will
start to see things the same way you do
so the entire burden doesn't have to be
on your shoulders
excellent thanks well we are um
running out of time and this was a great
way to
end of talking about how to bring in
groups of people right it's not just
yourself it's it's everybody involved
rob i want to thank you for having time
make the time to join us today and
share with all of us these great
concepts ideas approaches as we all you
know
enter this new world of digital
transformation
um with that again i want to thank
everyone for joining us today
it has been an absolute pleasure and we
wish you
a great rest of your day
you